how does the heart keep beating and
beating for years and never stop don't
stop won't stop heart beats for life it
just does you have a an sa node an av
node the purkinje fibers they go
throughout your heart and they help your
conduction if the electrical system is
there the musculoskeletal system will
listen as long as everything else is in
place you know oxygen electrolytes all
the good stuff okay so pathologists
study a tumor once it's removed but then
what does it get incinerated sent to the
dump shot into space well it doesn't get
shot into space because that'd be quite
expensive uh it gets thrown out in the
biohazard disposal what happens with it
then i have no idea but you've seen
those biohazard red bins that's where
the tumor goes and there's no need to
incinerate it
you don't need to burn it actually i
guess if there's like infectious things
in there maybe you do need to burn it
and it ends up being incinerated like
let's google what what happens
what happens to biohazard waste oh 90 of
biohazard waste is incinerated
the more you know an onlooker has the
choice to save five people being in
danger of being hit by a trolley by
diverting the trolley to just kill one
person we know dr mike would pull that
lever because he has no problem
murdering someone for charity hashtag
creator clash what is that i don't get
it oh because i murdered idubbbz for
charity i didn't murder him he's doing
great would you divert the trolley to
just kill one person oh man there's too
many other factors that i don't have the
information to and as a doctor who
thrives in the sea of nuance i refuse to
swim in this ocean
good answer
that's professional
[Laughter]
is it bad to draw on my hand with a pen
my mom tells me you give me pen cancer
never heard of pen cancer heard of pen
15 cancer if you know what i mean do
nipples grow back do they grow back
after what
my question if you had a traumatic thing
where you lost the nipple no just skin
would form there one two three music if
i scratch my mosquito bite will it get
itchier absolutely the reason this
happens is because of histamine
production the more you scratch the more
inflammation the more histamine the
bigger the hive the more itchy it
becomes and if you cause excoriations
which means openings in the skin you
could actually create an infection on
top of it which is a problem because now
you're gonna have to put steroidal cream
to decrease the itching and then an
antibiotic cream to fight the infection
is it true that if you chew gum while
studying then chew the same flavor gum
while taking the test you'll recall the
information you studied better it's
possible they say that you should try
and replicate your study environment as
much as you can during your testing
environment i think that probably goes a
step too far you're probably spending
more effort in trying to do this kind of
hacking thing than actually the effort
that you could be spending on studying
if you love chewing gum and you love the
minty flavors stick with the minty
flavor don't change and know that if you
cram you stay up all night it won't
enter your long-term memory the
information you studied is it weird to
go to a doctor for multiple things at
the same time what should i do if i have
several things to go over in only a few
minutes great question can we cover
multiple issues in one visit sometimes
yes sometimes no if your symptoms are
connected and can be pointing to one
universal problem that's causing all of
these symptoms if you have diarrhea are
sweating profusely or having
palpitations perhaps you're having a
thyroid issue and had you only presented
one of those concerns to me i might miss
the thyroid issue because i think oh
diarrhea maybe just an upset stomach
related to something you ate why
sometimes no well if you come in and you
say your foot hurts because you sprained
your ankle but then you also get
headaches sometimes and then you're also
due for your pap smear you could see how
we can't get all that done in one visit
but a good doctor will say what's the
most important to you and what they
think the most important is to address
in a given moment meaning what's the
most timely and then we can reschedule
you for a follow-up visit does it matter
when during the day humans get eight
hours of sleep i have friends who are
bartenders at night and then sleep
during the day if you're getting seven
to nine hours of sleep that's important
but then consistency is also important
and then also the time of day of sleep
is also important humans are not
nocturnal creatures so we need to be out
in the sun and that's how our circadian
rhythms work people who work during the
night and sleep during the day have more
health problems on average and we don't
have the exact reason as to why that
happens but we know that it's definitely
present we actually even have a disorder
called shift work disorder from
individuals who have that problem when i
have aches and pains i treat it with a
cocktail approach some acetaminophen
some ibuprofen some aspirin all at once
should i continue this approach or is
one better than the other is one better
than the other is actually a question i
get a lot from patients they're like i
have this ache or i have a fever all
three of these medications are pain and
fever reducers there's certain instances
where i would recommend one over the
other one is not the best for example if
you have kidney problems you may not
want to be taking an ibuprofen
medication which gets excreted through
the kidneys and can potentially damage
the kidneys if on the other hand you
have really bad liver disease maybe you
want to not be taking acetaminophen
because that gets metabolized within
your liver there's different instances
where you want to be smart for example
if you're prone to bleeding and have a
bleeding disorder aspirin can actually
inactivate your platelets and cause you
to bleed more i try and minimize the use
of these medications because reducing
fevers is not always a good thing a
fever is beneficial it's helping you
overcome whatever infection you may have
so unless there's a reason we shouldn't
be lowering a fever in many cases has a
patient ever come in with a disease or
condition you've never heard of before
absolutely remember i'm a family
medicine doctor anything can walk
through my door at any time and i have
to not only figure that out but also
maybe even learn about that condition
right there on the spot and the more
open you can be with the patient about
what you know and what you don't know
the better that line of communication is
going to be because not everyone can
know all the answers right away why does
taking a long deep breath help calm you
down because it actually activates your
vagus nerve that is the primary nerve in
your body responsible for
parasympathetic tone meaning your
ability to begin rest repair and
digestion if you're very riled up you
could have decreased activation of this
vagus nerve and as a result be very on
edge so when you take that deep breath
it actually helps normalize the
parasympathetic tone helps calm you down
and you chill out why do i sometimes
like the smell of my own farts okay
chrissy didn't expect that you'd go
there but there's actually a
psychological phenomenon that's
occurring here the longer your body is
exposed to a specific stimuli from
outside the body so for example when you
try and go to sleep white noise works
well because your body starts to tune
out the white noise because it's the
same level of noise that's why noise
that's a quiet and then really loud will
wake you up at night because it triggers
your brain to react to it but if you
constantly over time smell your farts
and smell your own body you become
accustomed to it so it doesn't trigger
that same level of response from your
brain so when others smell other farts
poop or what have you it triggers in
them that there's a foreign substance
potentially poisonous substance that
they should stay away from but when it's
your own your body is not having that
threat because it's been smelling it for
so long you have a decreased stimulus
response when people train to hold more
air in the lungs what exactly is getting
stronger do the lungs inflate more well
yeah the lungs can inflate more
hormonally things change cellular
cellularly things change like you're
able to produce more red blood cells you
have a higher hematocrit you're able to
withstand periods of anaerobic stress
for longer periods of time so you have
better lactic acid removal from your
body so it's not just like hold more air
in your lungs it's the processing of
being in an anaerobic state that is
equally important in this situation hey
dr mike my family tells me that eating
too much salt will melt my bones is this
true and if so how much salt is too much
melt your bones melt melt i don't know
is it ideal to eat too much salt no
there's recommended dietary intake for
every age group and it's different it's
also based on health conditions so i
can't give you an exact number but just
don't over salt your foods moderation
why are some people able to live well
into the 90s if they are heavy smokers
well this is important and it kind of
brings up the notion of what happens
when you have unhealthy habits too often
i tell patients hey you shouldn't smoke
and they say well my loved one lived a
long life and didn't even have lung
cancer but the important thing to
remember is not all smokers end up
getting lung cancer in fact most smokers
don't get lung cancer a lot of smokers
get diseases like copd emphysema these
are quality of life reducers and
quantity of life reducers so you may
live into your 90s but you have to live
with an oxygen tank and have such bad
destiny or shortness of breath that you
can't walk to the bathroom without
feeling a tremendous amount of air
hunger it's not just do you die it's how
well you live and with what conditions
you live
i miss draw my life videos so i made one
animated story of how i came to america
such a good one i bet you to know a lot
about me as always stay happy and
healthy
[Music]